[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits the podcast
where two lifelong friends talk about
life for a long time i am link and i am
red this week at the round table of dim
lighting link is going to be sharing
about a milestone a family milestone he
uh got started on the family game a
little bit earlier than me so want you
to the punch one year ahead of me
he is
pushing or he has pushed his first
bird out of the nest
um so not an empty nest yet
you know what i get to the empty nest
before you yes you do because i only had
two kids yeah you so i get to do the
first empty nest episode when that ever
happens if it happened whenever that
happened it was like emptiness is not
guaranteed for either one of us we both
got two in the house but you just pushed
one i mean not really completely out of
the nest if you pushed her to college
which is technically not she knows she
no longer lives at your house nope and
she's many many hours away
uh and i'm still getting used to it so
yeah i just i mean
i'm still gonna be processing this but i
just wanted to share the entire
experience
with you uh
i mean it
it's um it's
like you said it's a milestone event in
for our family and for lilly and as it
turns out it's even
there's been even more to process than i
anticipated and i thought it was going
to be a big deal so
uh
yeah i'll walk you through what it felt
like and maybe you'll be a little bit
more prepared but i'm sure
things will be different for you but if
if my story can help you in any way
dad rhett i wanna i wanna i wanna do
that for you well i'm sure you do
i mean because you you didn't help me
any i mean what is there to say you
don't know anything you know it's
uncharted territory it's like when i got
married you were like man you're getting
married i can't help you with that yet
of course i don't know how much i helped
you uh yeah
yeah i don't i don't recall getting any
i don't recall getting any advice from
you before i got married i just
demonstrate what not to do
that's a good point you know just watch
the good point yeah so it's just watch
and learn watching unlearn i have no
clue if there's any lessons that i
should be giving you but you can
probably glean things that
you'll approach differently than me
because
uh but
i if i can help by being a bad example
i'll do that
i don't think i did anything wrong yeah
i mean i'm for you now i'm intrigued now
i actually care about this episode
i'm just kidding but before we go any
further as of the release date of this
episode it's your birthday so
it i'm giving you the early birthday so
that as people are listening to this it
is the actual birthday october 11th
happy 44th birthday my friend you know
thank you for that uh we were actually
talking
uh with stevie the other day about the
phenomenon that people who do jobs like
us have to experience
and that is of course every single thing
i mean as much as many people on the
internet want to believe that every
morning we get up uh and record gmm
at about you know 1am
and then release it at 3am
or eastern standard time or well pacific
whatever it is uh that's not how it
works right we shoot things ahead of
time as link said it's not my birthday
but
we experience things or we try to convey
the experience of things like holidays
and birthdays yeah on the day that it
airs
but emotionally we're never really
prepared for that like you've we've also
already uh shot the good mythical
morning episode that will air on my
birthday
and i think you might have given me
there was a gift of some kind what do
you mean you don't remember the gift i
gave you well because it's a it's a blur
man because it wasn't really my birthday
i wasn't emotionally prepared to what
did you give me i don't remember either
yeah because
because you didn't give it to you it
wasn't it was given to you to give to me
right right
this is our life right we live in such a
weird world it was a book it was a book
about what i'm not going to tell you
because well i guess the episode is out
now so yeah i can't i can remind you it
was a book about
i think how
alphabetically oh how great of a person
you were and i read the book it was a
book yeah it was a book that you had
specially made for me i did yes yes and
uh and then i read it very loudly i i
decided on a comedic angle in the moment
right which i don't regret yeah because
otherwise you would have burst into
tears but yeah so i so this is putting
me in a place where i have to process my
44th birthday pre-process it um
i think that's good you know i it is
weird but this phenomenon that you're
talking about it really gears us up for
things i mean if we had to
pre-record stuff related to like
our wedding anniversaries and
special occasions
on that front stuff that like if you
forget it boy you're a you're a you're a
jerk and you're so this is a great way
to not forget that your birthday's
actually coming which can happen when
you turn 40 yeah that's true
what are you going to do um today well
what two things
one of the things that um
has struck me as i've reached my mid-40s
i don't know if this is i mean i guess
you're technically getting ready to
you're sort of like getting ready for
your mid-40s as well i don't know if mid
43 counts as mid i think you're
technically early 40s yes definitely
maybe more so than ever before the thing
i've started noticing is finding out
how old
certain people are are learning that
other
public figures are my age and thinking
i'm the same age as that person
but that's always been the case you just
it's new it's new celebrity feels new to
me like are you thinking about a
particular well i happen to see
michael buble on tick-tock
so you finally found your place on
tic-tac and uh
he was responding to i don't know if you
saw the uh what a crooner i don't know
if you saw the tick tock going around
that had you know i'm gonna say no uh
you you don't enjoy the tick tock i
enjoy looking at how our tick tocks are
doing but you don't you don't
you're not a student of tick tock i
don't i don't peruse it that often i
find tick-tock
just between you and me i know you're a
reddit man
uh i read it man i i'm a tick-tock i
take talk over reddit i know it's a
completely different thing but in terms
of like the place that it feels in my
life which is right before i go to bed
like a little bit of entertainment and
i'll use this as a teaser next week
we're gonna go
deep into tic toc
because of
something that
we we're doing on tick tock and
very excited about it well we can and
what we can tell you is that
this friday on tick tock
uh on the mythical tick tock which has
become very active if you haven't
noticed doing a lot of stuff over there
so we're talking about um
the 15th yeah yeah yeah um october 15th
we're gonna pull an all-nighter we're
gonna write a song we're gonna do it's
gonna be an interactive series
where we write record and produce a song
with your help you're not going to want
to miss it so
go to the mythical tick tock
which is
the only place i'm sure to go on
tick-tock and i know that hang out with
us and i know that many of you are
probably just like we are which is
friday night you're resistant to new
platforms for good reason you should be
protective of your time and your
attention
uh and then you you have this idea about
what tick tock is and it's kids dancing
and it is a lot of that
um but there's some really interesting
stuff happening over there and we're
really
trying some stuff over there so we're
gonna we're gonna talk about all of that
we're gonna debrief about just
what's happening on our tick tock over
this coming weekend
um
on the next ear biscuit but so yeah you
can save the rest of it but but back to
what i was saying
uh i don't know if you saw again
you didn't see apparently there's a
famous tick tock of a guy singing
multiple harmony parts
i can be brown i can be blue i can be
violent too i can be
done there's like six parts okay and
it's very satisfying
i mean i know you hate
music but uh it's very satisfying for
harmony lovers which i consider myself i
am mad that's that's the strength that's
the strange nexus of love and hate well
it's very impressive and by the end the
guy is singing really really high like a
lot higher than i can sing well
this has been parodied and redone
well ryan reynolds i guess recently
joined tick-tock and he did it and he
was singing it
and then
the way it stacks up is this like it
says what the part's gonna be and then
like the third part comes in and will
ferrell comes into the shot and it just
says will ferrell then he sings the next
two parts and it's funny and it's got
because they're on set together tens of
millions of views you know of course it
does
traditional celebrities decide to do
tick-tock and it's like everybody
jizzes in their pants
we ain't mad about it
um so uh
so michael buble
has a tick tock as well
and he made what's in his pants he made
a tick tock
where
he was responding to the fact that now
we know that ryan reynolds can also sing
and he was just like being very sad
about it because he was like singing is
my thing man
okay you can act you've got perfect abs
and now you we
find out you can sing as well
so i was like okay i think he's got a
alcohol brand he's got a great sense of
humor
so buble the crooner that he is uh
he he made the he i actually i don't
know if i finished the tick tock i got
the joke and i was like okay i get that
boo play i'm not necessarily a buble fan
but i was like oh he's got a few tick
tocks and i saw the first one so i don't
know how long ago this was
but it was basically him turning 46.
and it was like
he had two cupcakes one with the four
and one with the six and the six comes
in and he pushes it out and the four
comes in he wants to just be six but no
he's 46. he had to be there you had to
watch it
um
and i was like man well i'm not as old
as michael buble but i basically am like
we would be
contemporaries like we would have been
at height we were in high school at the
same time you know what i'm saying i was
like i didn't have any point of
reference for how old buble was but just
because he's like this crooner who's
like doing this throwback thing i would
if you'd have just randomly asked me how
old is buble i would be like 55.
like i haven't i haven't seen him i
don't i don't look i don't know how old
his face looks he doesn't look 55 it's
just in my mind
buble is 55.
at least he's not younger than you i
mean that would be the they're but
they're a crisis there are plenty of
people who are younger like i'm pretty
sure reynolds is younger
yeah there you're carol's not you're
right right plenty of people are younger
than you
i'm one of them um that's one thing the
second thing is i'm by i'm getting
myself a birthday present that's you
know that's the best thing to do even
though my wife said i already got you a
birthday present
well but you can still get your own you
don't know what that is yet oh you know
what kiko just let me know ryan reynolds
is 44.
so well
so we're the same age that's good too
then yeah again he's not younger than
you so there we go funny how he got back
to ryan reynolds and that bastard's 44
like i mean he he does everything he's
he's got abs he can sing he can act he's
got an alcohol brand and he happens to
just be the same age as me how many kids
does he have
i mean is there something we can have on
this guy i think i think maybe he
doesn't i know he doesn't have any maybe
i don't know
um i don't want to know who will find
that out in a second
so what are you getting yourself for
your birthday
well uh
better not be a motorcycle oh he's got
three kids he's got three
well how old are they
i mean there's got to be something he
goes googling so many things right how
old are i mean are his kids younger than
us is he like i think he's in the throes
of toddler them or something yeah surely
he's miserable he doesn't have a kid
leaving
at this point
uh so we'll find that out what i'm
getting myself uh is a guitar
you made a double neck no yeah of course
a keytar actually
you uh guitar one four and six so he
okay yeah yeah yeah yeah we got reynolds
your life sucks right oh man you have a
one-year-old you have a demon child yep
sorry man we got it we gotta we're
better than you man
so anyway um and i'm younger than you
well i think i am technically a little
bit too he was born in 76 but um i
recently you know one of the things
that's happened as i've gotten older is
i'm learning to get in touch with what i
actually like
and what i realized recently even though
i have three sorry i do have three
taylor guitars it's kind of a long story
i bought one for myself a while back
that was a little bit nicer we got a
less nice one for tour just in case it
broke and then it screwed up one night
so they bought a second one so i ended
up with these i got three guitars okay
but they're all kind of the same they're
well and they're all the same and none
of them are like really high level
taylor guitars but i had this thing in
my mind and a taylor guitar sounds great
and i remember there was this thing that
like
in my mind it was sort of like a
contemporary christian music thing when
we were in college like all the guys
were like playing like taylor guitars
and it it had it has this like a lot of
high end to it or something and it was
just like it was kind of like the shane
and shane thing that was happening like
the super fast strumming that was
happening back in the day
and so i thought oh i like taylor
guitars too but then i started realizing
that all the music that i enjoy people
don't play taylor guitars they're
playing martins and gibson's they're
playing these sort of like
older school sort of
more warmer more body kind of guitars
and i was like i i feel like i need to
finally just admit what i actually like
this is another aspect of your spiritual
deconstruction
it is part it is yeah i don't want to
say taylor is the christian guitar
because i don't i don't want to put that
on them and i don't think that that's
true
um
but yeah so i'm uh i'm actually looking
into getting a martin well i don't know
i'm going to go to a couple guitar shops
and play some stuff to get
yeah but you know one of the things
that's happening guitar technology over
over time is that martin and gibson and
a couple other companies are doing this
artificial aging and i'm not talking for
cosmetic purposes but they're basically
taking a guitar and making it out of the
same materials as a guitar from like the
30s or 40s and then they're doing a
thermal
aging which i guess is a fancy word for
baking
the wood
so that the guitar
essentially kind of like just takes
dressing genes takes on the physical
characteristics of an old guitar not for
cosmetic purposes for
audio auditory purposes so that you get
the tone that you would have to sit
around and wait 70 years for
so i mean you could just go for a 70
year old guitar do you think about that
there are a lot more expensive like
splur
i mean listen the the the
the artificially age is already a
splurge based on what i've looked at
like how much i mean you're not bragging
we're just talking we're just being
honest i i i mean i think i saw one for
like five thousand dollars
i don't know if i'm going to go that big
for a guitar but this but this is the
this is my guitar for like this is it
for my guitar that i'm going to die with
i bought you got to put it you got to
get me an extra big coffin because
you're going to bury me with it and you
know what
as
as frugal as i am i bought a bike an
upgraded mountain bike full suspension
and you know i dropped six grand on that
thing of course my birthday is in june
and i bought it a month ago because it
took me that long to work up the
gumption and then to actually find one
in stock but like that was a big splurge
but you know what i was on it this
morning it might have been the biggest
splurge you've ever done loving it uh
and when you my car was and when you
asked me
not to brag about my ability to guess
things but when you asked me out of the
blue how much do you think i paid for
this
i was within one cent yeah i guess
because it was a very round price
i mean like five nine ninety five or
something yeah but that i mean just to
pull a guess that was a mountain bike
out of the air i mean i've seen mountain
bikes in stores and they're really what
do you want me to do you buy you a
tailor yeah sing you a praise song so
you know what i should spend the exact
same amount on my guitar as you spin on
your body you should and then well we
can trade i'll ride your bike sometimes
you can play my guitar sometimes for a
guitar that expensive a strap might
round it up to six grand yeah one of
those straps probably included
oh in case probably included at that
when you get really expensive things
aren't included like
the freaking pedals weren't included on
my bike
i paid six thousand dollars for a bike
it first of all that's crazy but if you
want a full suspension bike i'm being
defensive here that this is like not
even a high-end well this is this is
something that you're doing and i had a
hard tail for years and i earned it okay
you this isn't this is an investment in
your personal health and you're in your
hobby i don't need to justify anybody
but i do need pedals which i had to buy
separately and i was like you're gonna
put these on for me at least who's who
are you talking to me i'm not doing it
the dude at the shop
i wouldn't know how to do that you
wouldn't trust me i try to put together
my bike that i got for shepard
uh that i got online for 299
and um i was putting it together and
broke it
and had to take it to a bike shop and
they were like oh another one of these
guys bring in a bike build your own
guitar that he wants me to put together
and you know what the bike shops do
around here when you do that they make
you wait like two months they punish you
because you didn't buy it from them
right you know what i got a lot i want
to share about sending my daughter off
to college you should do that let's get
into it but first let's promote some
merch what are we promoting all right
now we're in video territory see this ad
is only for you watching the video which
means now we can talk about hazel
in a
you know about it and if not you should
go to our tick tock if you don't know
anything go to our tick tock and watch
the whole series from last friday oh the
only spoiler is that everybody will
spoil that the only spoiler that we'll
give is that it's a lot more than two
guys sitting down to write an
interactive song okay it's something
that we've been working on for a really
long time and we're very happy and proud
of and hopefully it was received well we
don't know because and hopefully we
tricked you
um but we'll talk about more on that's
what we're going to talk about on the
next shirt that i have on that says
yearning by the macon brothers
uh
that's us you will understand the
placement in the story and the purpose
and the story and then maybe this shirt
would become meaningful to you but we
can't really tell you
uh what this shirt means and its
significance without telling you the
story which you need to experience in
real time cover up the y and it says
earning
yeah man are we earning your respect no
we're earning dollars when we sell that
shirt
so you can buy bikes
buy that at mythical.com rep your boys
literally in an alternate universe where
we're trapped in an album that oh
did i just spoil it uh
i mean you know no i think it's fine i
think it's fine mythical.com
um leading up to
lily
moving away to college
it i mean it was really something that
was on my mind
i didn't realize how much it had been
built up in my mind but i did have the
wherewithal
in about a month before
she left i took a day and as and i i
kind of carved out a day for me to have
like a a retreat day
you know when i'm like doing my own
reflection
and
i can lock out the outside world and i
can just take some time to
think and just me time you know it's
more like the isolation trips that we've
taken over the years sometimes you just
need
sometimes just taking a hike for an hour
or or two
or going on a bike ride
but
i devoted more time
to
to uh for myself and a big portion of it
was kind of thinking about and
anticipating what this process was going
to be like
and
uh
i was at the creative house
at one point
uh mike stopped by and i was talking to
him about how i was processing
everything and
um i was talking to him about it and
then i just realized i just said
sometimes you realize you're you're at a
point where you can
you feel emotion well enough inside of
you and you can make a choice to either
like
oh my my throat's getting tight
and i'm feeling kind of tingly i'm
i think i might cry
and it was
you know i'd kind of built up to
to that in my own process and my
journaling that i've been doing on my
own and but then i was sharing it with
him and i could tell that that was
happening
and i just made a decision i was like
you know what
he's a trusted friend he's here for me
if you were there if you'd have stopped
by i would have done the same thing with
you um
and
i just
started crying
and and the and i just said the thing
that like put me over the edge was
you know i'm gonna miss her so much
and like i'm getting emotional now just
because
i still do but
i knew that it was gonna be difficult
but it was nice to have this moment
where i could just spend a few minutes
and just
bawl like a baby
and
you know
mike's a good guy for that because he's
so he
he's such a good listener and
he welcomes
kind of sitting with you in that space
and he carries a handkerchief which he
uses to wipe your face no he didn't have
he didn't he didn't have a hanky
but it was just saying it out loud i am
going to miss her so much was
cathartic and also scary because it was
still
many weeks away
and
the thing that i realized
was that it was much more built up than
i had even thought
and i likened it to
like
when when christy and i were engaged and
then we got married she was talking
about how much of her thoughts and
expectations from a young age were
geared towards getting married that was
just something that she
um
[Music]
i guess fantasized about she visualized
her wedding day and i actually realized
that
i kind of did the same thing
with lily leaving home and
assuming she would go off to college
from a young age just kind of having
this image in my mind and it it it is a
it's a cultural trope right we watch
that um that animated movie
that was
eerily similar to what we were going
through this whatever the mitchell's
versus the mitchells versus the machines
and that's what the story is about and
we watched that as a family i might have
talked about it on your biscuits i know
i told you about it
um so
the idea of sending i guess especially
your first born off to college is
something that's like
it's really built up
and
i really i realized that definitely for
me with her and the nature of our
relationship
made that so
because i was at the creative house you
know i hung a bunch of
pictures up in there
uh just to start to put some finishing
touches we put finishing touches on the
creative house
uh christy and jesse both worked on
stuff over there introducing more plants
and everything into the situation
because of
what we're gonna film
and um
one of the pictures that i put up was a
picture of my mom you've seen it
and i got that one that you found when
you think you thought about this yeah
because i decided i didn't i didn't get
a memento and i went back in my nanny's
house to get something from the house
before it was like stripped clean
and i took this picture of my mom that i
remember always seeing and and i hung it
up in my office with some other pictures
in a group i also hung up the picture
the piece of art that was behind me when
we did the split screen episodes of good
mythical morning during the pandemic so
i'm trying and there's and i purchased a
picture that is a replica of the one
that was hanging over the mantel piece
at my nana and papa's house when i was
growing up so like these things that
connect to me i wanted to put those up
but
on this particular day when i was alone
processing how i was feeling and looking
at that picture of my mom
i realized
that
that picture of her was when she
was engaged to my got engaged to my dad
they took an engagement photo and put it
in the paper and like did the
wedding announcement thing like her
parents did that
and
that was the moment when
my mom
was leaving home for the first time
getting married and getting on with her
life separate from her parents and it
just hit me like a ton of bricks that
like
looking at that
version of my mom in the picture is the
place that
lily's at
in life
that the ages may be a few years
difference but the but the stage of life
of leaving home is the same and it just
and i couldn't help but feel
that
when i went back into the house to grab
something and that was the picture i was
drawn to
maybe i'm attaching meaning to it in
retrospect or maybe subconsciously
something was going on but i definitely
made this connection that
my mom
it lily is now going is now that age and
going through
this
crossing over into this next phase of
her life
and it was it was just a moving way for
me to
process and also realize
that she has lily has her own experience
going in this whole process and then i
have my own experience i started
thinking about my mom now and my mom
when i went off to college
um
and letting go of her
only son
and
uh
i just i realized that i had
well that christy and i had our own
experience
to
to go through our own journey in this
process that was separate from lily's
and it wasn't we want to support her and
celebrate
this
her her crossing over so to speak but i
also wanted to you might want to use a
different crossing over sounds like
she's dying right
moving moving on
moving moving forward getting on with
her life yeah let's just whatever the
most positive way to think about it and
that has been part of the struggle but
identifying that i have my own
experience in this that is separate from
hers and that is much more closely
related to christie's experience and i
just wanted to be committed
to
being there for it as much as i could
being as present as i could
um which is why
i've got notes because i've been writing
some stuff down that as i've been going
through this it's like what what does
this mean to me
um and how that's
it's not just a lily thing it's also
there's a me version of this you know
what i'm saying as the weeks
continued and it got closer and closer
to her leaving we started to have more
conversations about what it was going to
be like and lilly didn't want to talk
about it too much like and i could tell
it was because she was anxious so
actually having specific conversations
what
how do you visualize
that the move-in day how do you
visualize how we're gonna drop you off
and it was actually helpful because she
started saying things
um
well one of the things she said was
she admitted that she was concerned
about me being recognized
when she moves in yeah
and
christie she mentioned it to christy
first and christie mentioned it to me so
i like was able to
have more of a reaction with christy and
then figure out how i was going to
position myself in conversations with
lily and what disguise you were going to
wear and what disguise i was going to
wear exactly so
because it did kind of come to that we i
i was like i want to do whatever it
takes to support lily and whatever makes
her most comfortable and i do understand
that she's going off she's going to meet
a roommate she's going to meet people
during move-in and if that first
impression is associated if now she's
associated with this guy who's
famous on the internet
oh my god i watched your dad growing up
i mean not ryan reynolds not right
anything closer
no not anywhere close but just kind of
like except an age yeah and number of
kids right um
but not really anything i mean ryan
reynolds i mean he just couldn't help
his daughter move in like he couldn't do
it
i mean it would become ryan ryan
reynolds day at that particular college
yeah that didn't happen with you so i
wore a deadpool costume complete face
mask everything
but i was like so when i talked to lily
i was like mom told me
about your concern and i totally get it
and i don't want it let's let's just
have this conversation because i'm on
board for this i'm actually on board if
i
need to just sit in the car or like be
back at the airbnb and just be on
facetime or something
i'm i'm willing to do whatever
will make you comfortable
but i was really scared because i really
wanted to be there and so when i brought
it up to her i told her that and she
said
oh no you have to be there and it was
like oh that feels i'm so glad she said
that but i didn't say that i was like
okay cool but what let's then let's talk
about the details of this i can wear a
disguise
and she's like well wear a hat and don't
wear that mythical hat dad it's like
sometimes you think you're wearing a hat
people don't recognize you and it's a
mythical hat yeah not not real smart but
and i'm like good point i can also i'll
be wearing a mask the whole time
and
because that's going to be the rule and
i can also wear sunglasses the whole
time but when we're going inside you
know what i wear contacts
and i want i won't talk
you mean a lot you'll wear contacts and
not wear glasses i wear contacts so if i
take my sunglasses off i can yeah i'm
not wearing my glasses so it's one less
thing
that because people have still
recognized me with a hat and a mask on
so again i wanted to do everything
so
that was the plan
and
i felt good about it because i could
still be there so you're gonna be
dressed like the invisible man
yeah
yeah um
and then
i stole your idea of making a cameo so
christy and i and christy spearheaded
this
before we left we had we had dinner with
some some people that were close to lily
and then we surprised her with this with
a cameo montage of her favorite survivor
players over the years uh sending her
off like giving her
well wishes and advice for college
some of them would talk for like 15 or
20 minutes yeah and she absolutely loved
that that was the night before
we were leaving and it could have been
heavy and it i mean it's just a
brilliant thing it costs it costs some
money to get these cameos
but even if you like so a piece of
advice even if it's just one it's
totally worth it because she was she was
on cloud nine the rest of the night when
otherwise it would be like
this is my last night in my bed this is
before i go off to college i'm saying
goodbye to my cat i'm you know it's it
would it it was emotional and it really
helped
and i added a couple of hobbits there at
the end you got billy boyd was in it and
then um
why am i forgetting his name
samwisegamgee from uh also in stranger
things and uh yeah goonies uh what's his
name stan by me
sean aston shaun aston sean aston there
we go and and um you know you can tell
them what you can give them information
like you gave you gave all your cameo
people information about jessie some of
it was false most of it and so christy
gave like true information about where
she was going to school and studying and
all that stuff so it was cool to have
people talking about it
but then for sean
i said i want you to make a cameo for
saka the cat
because his owner lily my daughter is
leaving to go to college and saka can't
go
um
at least until her sophomore year when
if she moves off campus so you need to
tell him hey she still loves you she's
not going to be here that often but
she'll still think about you and she'll
facetime with you and there's limited
characters so i tried to get all that in
there and then he never sent one and he
never sent one and i was like this is
just stupid and then um i made the cameo
clip
and he wasn't in it
and then uh lily was so excited when she
was going to bed she was like give me
the log in the cameo
and so i can look i can watch these
again in my bed
and then when when i gave her the login
she was like there's another one here
from sean aston
and i'm like yes he did it let's play it
and then we played that one and like he
got the assignment totally wrong
but he's like the sweetest guy
like he's like freaking samwise gamjee
enrolled how did he interpret it and
then he would just like was
talking about college and i think at one
point he thought that lily was soccer
but then i could tell in the middle of
his and he went for like over 15 minutes
very generous
i could tell that he glanced down his
information and he was like
uh
i got this all wrong
and then he's like he took a breath and
then he started talking to saka and he
did it and it was it was that's great
amazing and it just
that i mean i got to give you credit
that was a brilliant move and it really
worked for for her i didn't invent cameo
as much as i would like to uh
to take credit for that so we all go as
a family um and we're you know it's a
long drive i'm intentionally not talking
about where lily's going to college
because i don't want to
you know
um and i don't want there to be any
speculation about it either but
many hours away
uh long drive
we're driving at night
because we had stuff to shoot during the
day and then we all hop in the car i'd
pack the night before
and um
so
the plan was we get there that night at
the airbnb the next
day we move her in
but then we're going to stay at the
airbnb that night we'll get up the next
she'll stay in her dorm get to know her
roommates
plural
i'll get to that and then
the next day we can get her any supplies
she needs we can have dinner we can say
goodbye that night we'll still say at
the airbnb after we said good goodbye to
lily
we'll get up the next morning we'll
drive back home so that's what we did
that was the plan we get there the first
night everybody's exhausted they go to
bed at the airbnb but i had been super
caffeinated to like for the long drive
and so i instituted what became a
nightly ritual which i would go for a
walk
around it wasn't the college town but it
was like an adjacent town over
where we could get an airbnb so it was
it
there was
it was 1am and i'm walking around
and again it's another time when i'm
just
making a decision to process my emotions
and
my thoughts and memorialize this event
um
for myself and be present for it
and i'm walking around this uh
associated town to a college town but
not the college town at 1am and there is
nobody there it was the strangest walk
i've ever taken in my life
there was nobody no signs of life
anywhere but there were a good number of
airbnbs around but it's just i guess
it's just not not people in them
businesses closed outdoor seating for
like some restaurants
that weren't put away
nobody i saw i saw a police officer
drive by and that was it
no homeless people i mean we're used to
seeing homeless but you walk around
home you know people who are
experiencing homelessness is what you're
supposed to call them and there's
they're outside none of that so it's
just like strange i started taking
pictures
of nothing
it was like a it was like an abandoned
amusement park it was weird
without any rights
and then i'm like damn
there's
a statue of a skunk that's weird
and then i'm like god
because it was like an actual skunk it
was frozen and it was like totally
stretched up a statue of his and it was
i mean it wasn't moving at all and his
mouth was open like it had been
taxidermied
and then i realized
oh my freak
that's a skunk
a live skunk and i like backed away i
was just i mean i was as far from moving
that camera as this skunk and his tail
was up but it wasn't facing me yet and
then it i've actually never
uh walked up on a skunk i just walked up
on a skunk literally
two nights ago
we were at our friend's house together
and we were leaving texted us
and he was like
there's a lot of skunks in our
neighborhood in los angeles and i was
like
okay he's like you might just watch him
as you're walking to your car and i was
like
this is a center it's a thoroughfare
this is a weird piece of advice was it
frozen when you saw it it was yeah i did
not for a moment think that it was a
statue or a lawn ornament but yeah it
was
and it was your loss arched back tail up
facing away from me as i walked past it
like ready to squirt is that the crap
correct uh no spray spray
ready to spray
and uh so i backed away and just kept
walking but i was like he was right man
there's skunks all over this he walked
away and um
then i finished my walk
i didn't get too emotional that night uh
because i was like
tomorrow's
the big day um we move her in
the next afternoon so we had some
quality time together eating late
breakfast there's a whole rigmarole to
move her in especially with covid
protocols and like stretching people out
so you're just you had to sign times and
there wasn't a swarm of people because
they had taken care to isolate now
lily
was
had met
a potential roommate online
and they requested they hit it off so
they requested a room together even
though she was thinking about requesting
a room alone
a single person room because she's an
introvert
well when when her and her
roommate got the assignment they were
together
but
there were also four other people in the
room i'm not talking about a suite i'm
talking about one room one space with
with
loft beds and bunk beds all over it like
six six
women in a room
together i was like talk about polar
opposite of what you wanted or thought
you needed that's intense man
and i was like and she had emailed and
said put me on a waitlist for a smaller
room none of that came through so we
knew we were moving in or into a room
with all these other people and some of
them had moved in
um and so when we when we moved her
stuff in i'm in my get up mask
sunglasses contact lenses hat
non-mythical hat not a mythical hat
we've we put all our stuff in a cart and
we take it up to the room we're looking
at the room we're walking a little bit
different
yeah yeah yeah not nearly as cool no no
less cool we get into this room and
there are other her roommates uh a
handful of men already moved in
and
it was quiet
like there was no music playing nobody
was talking
and then
and i made up my mind i'm not gonna be
i'm not gonna talk
because
people would recognize my voice
and this is something we talked about
i'm gonna you know i'm gonna keep quiet
is what i said well i didn't anticipate
that me keeping quiet would would like
really
set the tone that when this family comes
in to move lily in they're really quiet
like like lando didn't talk lincoln
didn't talk then christy was like
whispering to lily and then all of a
sudden i realized this is the strangest
you guys are moving into a museum it it
felt so weird
because they because the girls who were
already in there weren't talking and
because it was and i felt like there was
this awkwardness like all right another
roommate's moving in we're going to need
to meet her but her parents are here her
two younger brothers are here
it's a little strange but then
it basically became like
silence and that was really strange
because i didn't want to be like
because what i would have done normally
was like hey it's kind of quiet in here
you want to play some music or
you know everyone can speak freely and i
would have embarrassed lilly
so it was actually good that i was i i
kept kept my vow of silence but it like
permeated in a very weird way that i'll
never forget her move-in was just that's
weird yeah silent it feels like the
other we either
i mean this is like we were sneaking
around like we weren't supposed to be
there the challenge of that many people
in a room you feel like i'm gonna leave
for a while while
this other person moves in but you can't
really make a policy where you leave the
room every time
things get shaken up a little bit
because even you'll never be in there
right
uh so we got we got in and out of there
and then
it wasn't the big goodbye it was like
hey
stay the night
we'll pick you up tomorrow we'll go
grocery shopping and stuff we'll see you
again so
it was cool and it kind of we had the
luxury with a couple of nights to let
her ease into it you know so
um
we left
and
we went back to the airbnb and that
night i went on
um
uh
another walk
well i'd actually
before we moved in we had we had written
her letters so like the first morning we
got up chris and i each wrote her a
letter and then we actually got the boys
to write her a letter too and then when
in her journal and stuff where she was
when she was moving in we kind of put it
in a strategic place where she would
find it
you know
um
but then
that night after moving her in and her
not being at the airbnb with us i took
another walk that night and uh
that was
it was a little bit more emotional i
found myself starting to have like
dramatic thoughts like
from now on every time lily comes home
from college it's gonna feel different
like she's no longer gonna be she's
gonna come home as like a visitor
versus someone who lives here you can
only hope it's gonna
yeah i found myself thinking okay this
is a definitive end of an era
but the truth is hey you never know what
can happen
i mean pandemic's an example but there's
so many things that can happen it's like
oh you know what
you are going to move back home for a
little bit
at some point you know so it's but i
tend to like because i want to be so
present i acknowledge that i tend to
like really dramatize things um
maybe more than is necessary but i think
hey if that makes it more fun but also
more emotional and more meaningful i
just want to be here for it and some of
it maybe i'm conjuring you know
that's just my approach to these these
things we get up the next day
this was like the dreaded day that led
up to the actual goodbye
and
um you know so the grocery shopping we
went out to dinner
i resisted the urge to turn dinner into
like one more big speech moment ever
let's go around and everyone tell
lily something special about her let's
give her some encouragement about how
she's going to be at college like i
didn't you know
she would she wouldn't have loved that
so like we kept it just kind of like oh
it felt like a normal dinner
we're doing good
we get we get back we get back in the
car and then lando just
he gets emotional and then he's like
crying for like
all the way there like he just cried a
lot and it was like poor buddy he's just
so sad and it's like that was his moment
and then we're like standing out in the
parking lot and i picked a place where
there wasn't trap like foot traffic
where we could
have our moment and it was like
okay everybody's got to say their
goodbye and you know what i'm going to
position myself to be last i want to be
last
i didn't tell anybody that but like
lando was crying so he went first she's
like consoling him and
lincoln and lily had their inside jokes
and saying goodbye and like christy's
like embracing her whispering in her ear
and then like
then it's my turn and i like
embrace her and like she's crying and
i'm crying and i'm like saying like
you got this we're so excited for you
and then she's like
mom i already said the exact same things
like yeah where that's the problem with
going last man we're a team to bring
something new to the table and then uh
did you see other groups of parents like
no was there earl earlier like the day
before and
we saw a couple of tearful goodbyes so
yes we had seen it happen and that's why
i was like i need to pick a better place
in this parking lot where people won't
be seeing us because i just don't want
that to be a factor so it was it was
nice it was beautiful it was
um
it was
happy and sad at the same time chris and
i've been talking about that casey
musgrave song a lot and how it really
applies that like at every moment of
feeling deeply sad
there's a there's a companion thought of
this is something to celebrate and this
is a new beginning for her and this is
uh this is an exciting opportunity
you know there's a lot of things to
celebrate right so
it's both at the same time
i
i end my embrace and then
she walks away and i'm like pulling out
my camera and taking a picture of her
walking away and i'm like this is the
moment that youth that i've thought
about ever since lily was born is just
seeing her
walk away and now every time she walks
back she's it's a different arrangement
she no longer is under my roof she's no
longer
well i still feel like she's my
responsibility but
the terms of our relationship have
shifted the environment is totally
different you know she's
she's crossed over into
into new life
and i go back i'm like man i really need
my walk tonight
and uh
i walked
back i
take my walk didn't see the skunk
and i just found a place to sit down and
that that's when like
i just had this like
shoulder jumping like body heaving just
crying just like
letting just letting it all out and it
just it felt good to be able to do it i
feel like i go through so much of my
life knowing that there's something in
there
that
i know it hurts
but it just it's it's hard to let it out
it's hard to like
not to stop it at the throat and
uh
so i'm like all right this is this is
part of it i can't remember the specific
things i was thinking
but i need to remember because if i ever
have to be an actor and cry again
this is the moment i should go to that's
trouble but like i think there were
there were some people around because
this was much earlier this wasn't 1am it
wasn't a ghost town and like just seeing
some dude just like
just like body shaking crying the walker
the walker is out again and then i'm
walking and it was good
you know and again that was for me it's
like i sure i cried on lily's shoulder
when she was crying on my shoulder but
it wasn't to the point i didn't i wasn't
going to be a wreck in front of her
because that's not a great way to send
her off i didn't want her to i didn't
want to add one one shred of doubt that
like i'm not going to be able to handle
it right you know
but if she would have seen me at that
moment i've been like oh god do you need
to go to the emergency room
you know so i even i surprised myself
uh
and it
it did feel like an achievement of oh
god i got it out
and i'm walking back feeling lighter
and i took a different route i knew
there was this path like around these
town homes in this like creek that
wasn't it was like a dirt path and i'd
walked it during the day and i walked it
there was some lighting so i i said i'm
gonna walk this this way back tonight
it's my last night here
um
and
the lights
at first
then they started to diminish and by the
time i got further in on the path behind
these houses i also i started to feel
like a like i was some sort of creeper
like i was in people's backyards
and it's like this look different during
the day
but at night i don't feel like i should
be here and i'm starting to have these
doubts and there's a lot of darkness on
the path and then all of a sudden i hear
somebody say i mean no harm
and
the sound was not coming from a great
way a human height
the sound was coming from the ground it
was coming from skunk height in the
darkness
the talking skunk i recoiled
like
i i didn't say anything i went
and i
like a shaggy from scooby-doo pose on
like the dvd cover like it's kind of
like no harm i put my left shoulder
forward and like
oh i said
and when i didn't say anything and i
still couldn't see anything but it was a
person squatting
and that person who meant no harm then
said
i'm just a woman
and i start to look and i squint my eyes
and
i saw this like puddle
and it was a woman
squatting and peeing
behind the town home i think she had
left the bar
or something she had left like they she
was on a walk with somebody she had to
pee really badly because she was like
dressed to go out
um i mean from what i could tell
and she she had she had to pee and would
you have seen her if she had said
nothing i would have walked right over
oh and it that would have really scared
the crap out of me slipping on a woman's
pee what did you say uh
she said i'm just a woman and i'd i was
like
oh it's okay and then she stood up and
she walked she came towards me and then
hung a hard left and like went back up
through two town homes did she finish i
didn't ask her that but i think she did
it was quite a puddle
a flowing puddle
and i was like uh yeah i'm just uh gotta
get
you could have done this that's why
citizens arrest for public urination
that's been cool i mean no harm
i'm just a woman too late woman she i
was standing in the light she could see
me clearly and she could tell that i was
absolutely terrified
of this this
i don't know it could have been like a a
squatting bridge troll for all i knew
right you know changing changing its
voice just drooling lily had asked he
was like you're not you know why don't
you come by in the morning
before you leave town i'm like no no no
no no this is it this that was before we
said goodbye she was trying to delay it
and uh like no no no we have to
we got to hold firm it's like we can't
we can't we can't delay this we can't
have another goodbye one more day
we'll talk to you book
and um
you know
just to reverse a little bit when i was
like crying and shaking before i saw the
woman who peed and meant no harm
uh
i did
like after i had a good cry i i texted
lily and she like responded and like we
had a good exchange and it was
i took a screenshot of it for my for my
own memory to just be like this is the
first conversation we had where she's
no longer my daughter it's like i'd
think dramatic things like that of
course she's still my daughter it's like
what's wrong with you you think dramatic
things really
it really helped when like we had that
text exchange and uh
the next morning we get up we pack up
our stuff we got a whole lot less crap
and uh
we we took the day leisurely driving
back
and now
having been
a few weeks of her
being
off at school it's like she's she's off
to a really good start she's
she's made friends with her roommates
she's they've had fun together she
started her classes
it's it's so far so good you know i mean
she's she i can tell she definitely has
her doubts of like did i make the right
decision is this too far away
i
you know i i don't have a car i'm using
public transportation what is that what
is all i'm figuring out so many things
and like it feels like i remember how it
felt like we were close to home and we
came home every weekend stuff that we
talked about but still it was like
it feels like okay
her future hangs in the balance
depending on how this goes and i'm not
telling i'm not being over dramatic to
her again i keep that to myself and just
giving her encouragement but i am
encouraged that she's doing well when we
facetime she's smiling she and she wants
to face time and she wants
but and she still misses us but
it's um
it's going good
but now we're trying to figure out all
right how do we conduct our relationship
and what does that look like how much
should i be texting and christy and i
are talking how much should we be
reaching out and and pushing for details
and or letting her reach out to us and
there's this dance of figuring out
uh how
how we conduct our relationship now you
know because there's there's some
feeling that out and
and also setting some precedent
that like okay this is we're gonna we
started a new
text chain
with the three of us and
uh i'll get mad if christy texas texts
her sometimes outside of the chain or
vice versa and it's like oh we want to
be included in the conversation and
figuring out okay i don't know
i don't want to i don't want to start
asking a bunch of questions and maybe
make her feel like i'm checking up on
her so i'm just going to send her a
picture of the cat
and then if she responds
then i'll know that like she's in a
position where maybe she can talk and
i'll see if she can facetime and
or other times it's
i find myself
chris and i were talking last night
her bedroom in our house is like in the
middle of the hallway and so no matter
where you go in the house herb that's
the central point
and
so we always walk by it and the doors
open and everything's fixed in our room
and
um
i just find myself it's like
that's the reminder it's like this
constant reminder that oh she's she's
not in that room anymore i mean you're
not immediately turning it into a gym i
mean we were joking about what we were
going to turn the room into but it it's
just going to be there for her to be the
same when she comes home for
thanksgiving or christmas break
but like yeah i found myself going by
the room and just walking in there and
standing
you know
and uh
or checking on the litter box oh that's
why i'm in here i'm in here to check on
the cat's litter box
or if the dog took a [ __ ] in there which
he does yeah jasper's got yeah he's got
some issues when you when when you were
hanging out the other day you can't i
was gone for a while and then you found
me in lily's room
cleaning up the dog [ __ ] that i had
stepped on
and almost slipped to the floor
but yeah it's just like
i don't know it's
making decisions like i'm not gonna go
and just stand in her room
and just be sad
you know i'm gonna have to channel that
into something
um
and then but
you know i'm just
i'm and i shared this in the good
mythical more episode where i talked
about our matching tattoos but just
the fact that when when she
is 18 and she's moving out of the house
that we have a relationship where she
wants to get a matching tattoo with me
it just it it meant so much and
we got so close over the pandemic like
late nights on the weekend when it was
just like i'm gonna hang out and watch
stuff late at night and
she's gonna stay up late making mac and
cheese and so that's when we connect and
hey i'm watching this you want to come
in here and watch watch this let's let's
hang out so like
we over the pandemic we really became
friends
and
i'm just
you know it's it's kind of the thing
that i would that you hope will happen
with your kids and i didn't realize how
much that was
my specific goal that to state it in
terms of her leaving that
when she goes
when she moves out of the house
i want our relationship relationship to
be such that
she wants to face time she wants to
reconnect we still have stuff that we're
talking about that's not it's the nature
of the conversations is not just about
i'm it's dad checking up on you
and trying to get information out of you
and details you know
or
she calling me saying i need money or i
need this or i need that you know of
course we want her to be able to come to
us when she needs stuff but i still want
her to want to have a connection and
it's a tremendous blessing
of the pandemic that i think
with her being so limited in who she
could be with the fact that we all found
a way to enjoy each other and it really
it really set us up
and gives me hope that like
it's not
you know the goodbye was not it's just a
it's a change of
practices with our relationship but it's
not in any way the end of our
relationship
that i would sometimes internalize and
dramatize that way
so
you know the when i go downstairs for a
late night snack and usually she'd be in
there and we'd be having a conversation
now it's like
well i'm gonna get lincoln out of his
room and get him off of his video games
and say hey son you gotta step it up
because
lily's gone you got to be the friend
that she was to me like i've told him
that
and
he's laughed but like yeah it is an
opportunity
i
i really think about the lesson learned
for like with lily to in a positive way
to like
create me and lincoln's version of that
over the next two years
but yeah i go to the pantry and
i'm like there's lily's cereal the one
that she said i couldn't have so i'm
like sending her a text and saying do
you have your permission to eat the rest
of your strawberry honey bunches of oats
and she's like
no
you got to save it for when i come home
and i'm like and she's like just kidding
you can have it i'm like i
i texted our picture the empty bowl and
i'm like too late already ate it you
know so it's just making
we're at a phase now where we're still
trying to figure out how how do we keep
the relationship active
and
keep that keep that bond going
and
being able to celebrate and give her
give her the support and strength she
needs to like
keep looking forward and not not start
looking back to us you know yeah but
it's that's pretty much the experience i
wanted to share
and i'm just i'm grateful that it has
been
pretty heart-wrenching for me you know
because it just says a lot about our
relationship and
uh but it's it's for the best and i
believe in it
you seem like you're dealing with it
well but it may not and it may be
totally different with the boys
well you know
that what i've been thinking about as
you've been uh talking and i'm not
saying because they're boys but
um but for all factors i'm different
than you
locke is different than than lily
our families are different in some ways
one of the things that i think ever me
and locke have in common and jesse also
like we're we're very we're very we're
always kind of thinking about the future
like we're all we're kind of always on
the next page
yeah and a lot of times when people
aren't on the next page it's just like
why are you still why are you still on
this page because we're already in the
next chapter right
and so locke
has a tendency i mean if you go if you
think about the way that i treated
college i do think it had something to
do with the fact that we went to school
close sure but i've ventured to guess
that if i hadn't gone to school a state
away
um
it wouldn't have been much different
like the process of my parents dropping
me off
would have been like i'm not saying my
dad would have just shaken my hand like
in an old 50s movie but it would have
been like the 90s version of that like
well we weren't friends with our parents
i mean it was that was not something
that
was a part of the equation i mean so and
but and i know you have that yeah so i
i'm definitely
me and locke are friends
uh but he also he's so much like well
there's a couple of dynamics one he's so
much like me that
we like expect like you talk about how
during the pandemic you can literally
got close like during the pandemic me
and locke being close to each other was
actually a huge source of conflict like
he you know him he's got his own ideas
about everything and he is a challenger
he's an enneagram eight yeah um he does
the whole going with the flow or being
on like going with the being a part of
the program and a part of the plan it's
like but his nature is to figure out
what the plan is and then depart from it
and that is a that can be a it's a
difficult thing as
a parent that we are kind of constantly
battling each other right and so there's
a lot of you know there's a lot of um
sort of tension
oftentimes in our communication yeah the
the good news is that we communicate
very frequently about
basically everything so he's not like a
lot of teenagers that are like i've got
all this stuff that i'm thinking about
and doing that you don't have any idea
about
it's like we talk about everything
um
but it's a lot of times it's it's an
intent there's an intensity to the
conversation and not a hey we're just
chilling we're like having we're working
through something
so i think it's like finding the time to
be like how can we have some
hang time
some intentional hang time
to kind of lay the groundwork for that
for the rest of your life yeah and it
what you're saying makes me think of how
my the terms of how lincoln and i
interact and the bond that we have is
different and it's not fair and it i was
joking and i
i hope that i think that he knew that i
was juggling i'm like hey you got to
step up because lily's leaving like i
actually don't know if he's like i think
the dad like lily was dad's favorite
like i don't know
i don't think it's to that point or that
like i want you to then fill the hole
that she's left
because the relationship with each child
is is totally different i mean the stuff
that jesse was talking about two
episodes ago about parenting
uh yeah that's ringing in my ears now in
terms of
each each
child is different and so the nature of
your relationship is is different of
course it is that's how relationships
work
it's interesting when you look at
certain milestones in the future and
you're like especially for me i'm like
i'd like for it to be this way
and then i need to acknowledge that
first of all i'm not in charge of it and
i don't
and i don't need to control things to
make them the way that i want them to be
but there's
there's certain values that i want to
build into our relationship so that
there's some fundamental truths
associated with our experience
that are different than like me
controlling the minutia of
like curating an experience so it's
just like a communication climate that
hey we're like like what you're talking
about
so it's yeah you're not get
you absolutely know that you're not
going to replicate your experience my
experience with lily with lock and
it's a good reminder that i'm not going
to do that with lincoln either
because it's just that doesn't make
sense that's not how relationships work
right but as a parent
you do look forward to things like and i
i think that for me
what i just went through with sending
lily off is is gonna is was more
emotional than
if if and when she gets married uh i
don't know did i give that impression
because i actually i i think i could be
wrong but i think that's i definitely
think so because the transition between
right leaving home is much more
personal to you but it's not the one
that i mean when you think about the
father of the bride and i of course i'm
going to be emotional but like i just
don't think it will be to the extent
that i just i just went through it well
for the sake of the wedding guest i hope
not
right
what's wrong with his shoulders good is
he does he need to go to the er yo yo yo
uh
just got speech jammed
but
as a parent looking for i mean i started
to think about
like okay when all the kids are out of
the house
i want them to want to come back and go
on a vacation i want to go on like a
extended family vacation i want them to
be to bring their significant others
back with them and hey we're going we're
going to do this together let's go well
just pay for it and that'll take care of
itself
so i visualize these things but like
you know
ultimately it comes down to
you want to cultivate
a meaningful active relationship and
then it takes two to tango yeah you want
to be a resource for for her
um because the nature of the
communication with our kids like you
said i mean
just simply
by way
by way of having a phone
and being able to be in the more
constant communication the fact that we
know i can
it gets late and i look at my phone to
figure out where lock is like think
about right how different of an
experience that was from what we had
like
we we could have been and should have
been dead many times
you know when we were their age the
stuff that we did mostly at the bottom
of a river yeah and uh but now it's just
like
oh it's 12 30. black's not home oh i see
i see the street that he's on right now
i know whose house he's at
let me okay you know it's like we don't
have that on for lilly at this point she
didn't want that and it's like well yeah
i mean now that she's like now she's 18.
but just the being able to be in that
constant communication is something that
now you have to think about like okay
what part of this
am i
uh am i doing for me and what part am i
am i doing for
her because i think yeah because i think
about that whole vacation example and it
starts to i hear myself and it kind of
feels like well that's a nice dream
there's no guarantee of that but it also
kind of feels like an expectation that
our kids lives as they build their own
lives are going to still kind of revolve
around our family unit and that's that
is
i think that's why it's emotional
because i know that that's shifting and
i know that i took
my immediate family away from our
extended family when we moved out here
and that they just don't have the same
connection that i hope to maintain with
my kids but that may mean me chasing
them across the country because
i know that their lives aren't going to
revolve around i mean that may mean the
nature of your relationship or the
nature of how
often you see them physically in the
same space
may change i mean one of the things that
you you said earlier you were like
you know i made sure to not have this
breakdown in front of her or i made sure
to kind of keep those things from her i
mean
for better or worse
you have like
that is a
that's kind of
that's not happening
your emotions and the way that you're
processing it lily is 100
feeling that and interpreting that like
everything that every look on christy's
face every change in the tone of voice
with both of you your kids pick up on
all that sure you can have this illusion
in your mind that you're keeping it from
and boundaries are important but what
i'm saying is that
your kids know everything that you're
feeling and everything that you're
thinking and so it's more it's more
about managing
managing it and like keep keeping
yourself in check but you don't begin to
believe that like oh she has no like she
knows exactly how you're processing this
but i but it that doesn't mean you
should do it in front of her i agree
with your decision he could have yeah
but you're right you're right but it was
like that moment that i was talking it
was like i didn't let go and i'm like
i'm gonna miss you so much yeah yeah
yeah you want you don't you don't want
to make it about yourself and so
separating yourself in in in but i'm
saying that in terms of
the emotional sort of quality that is is
coming out and yeah we we put all our
[ __ ] onto our kids just like jesse said
it's harm reduction at this point
because everything that we think that
we're keeping from them is actually
seeping out
um that doesn't mean you don't set the
boundaries it's just it's an awareness
that like oh she's totally she totally
knows how difficult
this this was i mean one of the things
is like you know
one of the things that i saw in some in
so many families throughout the the
pandemic is like
uh
anxiety over covet
that parents had was transferred like an
avalanche on the kids yeah even if you
think you're keeping it from them right
you know what i'm saying if you've got
anxiety if you were worried constantly
about it
your kids
inherited that and took that on you know
it's just like that that's and we were
with them so
so regularly that you just can't you
can't help it so it's more about being
okay what have i
unintentionally
passed on to them like what emotional
qualities have they picked up and how
can i
how can i minimize that and undo that as
much as i possibly can before they go
out into the world and put it on other
people yeah and now it's like all right
she is out in the world
it definitely feels like all right but
let's see what the next four years hold
and like
where she's really out in the world it's
like there is there is there's i can
feel that there's another stage of like
college world is not the real world
uh so
that kind of mitigates it too that's one
of the great things about it you know
what we've done
we've done a good job that's what i tell
christy it's like we we're far from
perfect
and but we we've succeeded at
minimizing
harm by pre and projecting that
uh to the point where
like she's she's doing her thing yeah
yeah all right i'm not worried about
lilly
i'm not worried about you either i'm
worried about you
[Laughter]
i'm doing good man i had to get my own
cereal i couldn't use that excuse
anymore well this is lily cereal i just
happen to be eating it
you got a wreck this is your wreck
i do
um
i happen to listen to
an episode of rain wilson and reza
aslan's podcast metaphysical milkshake
guest was jason isbell
my favorite
contemporary artist
um
who somebody on twitter did point out
that i had been saying his last name
incorrectly by saying isabelle
incidentally whenever he's a guest on
anything including metaphysical
milkshake
like they said isbelle but when he
introduces himself it is isbl so i'm
going to respect jason and start saying
isbell okay um well then call him mr
isbell so mr isbell is a guest on this
podcast
uh in the in the episode title was where
does music come from and man i just
every time i hear this dude talk i just
my level of respect and admiration goes
up like his i gotta listen to it i saw
your tweet and i i responded to it yeah
you thought that i had been a part of
the conversation i realized later that i
did make it i said thanks for the
conversation thanks for the insightful
and delightful conversation it was like
oh no like was he on earbuds without
saying thanks for having an an
insightful and delightful conversation
so yeah um
and it's it's so interesting because
they're talking about it and they kind
of come from different places right you
know rain and and reza are kind of
coming from uh more kind of more of a
spiritual standpoint in talking about
where this inspiration comes from and
and
jason is kind of like well that's not
really my perspective but the way they
meet in the middle and kind of
and he actually literally talks about
his songwriting process oh cool and then
he demonstrates reign gets him to pick
up a guitar and demonstrate how he
begins to write a song oh whoa
it's you know it's just a cool toy
didn't do it for me but this is this
it's uh yeah i just and his insight into
the perception like the like the way
that certain kinds of music got to him
in alabama and the way it kind of
changed the way his his began to change
his worldview like
really awesome conversation so meta
metaphysical milkshake uh
episode where does music come from when
jason is bull i don't recommend it
boy we we parented hard today if you
want to hear more about us talking
parenting stuff we
were doing live
facebook audio interviews with other
dads like terry crews that was an
amazing conversation so that lives on
our mythical facebook page
um
and so hashtag your biscuits let us know
what you think about this
from
from whatever perspective you're coming
from maybe that's parent maybe that's
otherwise and
remember
this coming friday
big tick tock hang with us on our
mythical channel it's going to be fun
you're going to want to be there
and then
that's why we've already planned on next
week's ear biscuit that we're going to
unpack
that that whole experience and a lot of
tick tock stuff that we're thinking
about yeah whether you like tick-tock or
not
we're gonna make we got we're gonna make
you like tick-tock
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe if you prefer to listen to
this podcast it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms thanks for
being your mythical best
[Music]